the jurogan experience hey i love your
[ __ ] movies
i i love the 75 and i really
enjoyed silk road it was really good and
you did a great job
of taking something that is a real story
and laying it out in a movie format
where you only have like a certain
amount of time with actors
but even the guy who played the bad cop
what is his name jason clark i love that
guy he's great
he's been in a bunch of things yeah he
was in chappaquiddick
he was in first man he's been in a bunch
of stuff and he's just he's a beast
um you know it was so interesting when i
got there on set with him
and it's like sort of you know day one
you don't know what you're getting into
and i'm and i was just standing there
next to him and i was like
dude this guy is like a thoroughbred
race horse and he is at the kentucky
derby i can't wait to see what this cat
does
yeah he's so good as a bad guy yeah
he's he's game for it yeah yeah he's
he's intense
i've seen that guy in so many movies
he's just one of those guys
like you see him and you're like oh that
guy well you know it's so funny when
you're like
you know i sat down so i'd written the
script for silk road
several years ago and you know i have
done all these documentaries that's my
background right which is kind of where
you dive into the
you know you do the deep dive on these
um you know crazy crime stories that's
my whole
that's my whole racket you know from
michael dowd forward and then you
you know go into the world suddenly
going from the dock thing into the movie
thing
and it's like well who are the people
that are going to inhabit this so i sat
down and i met with
you know all these amazing actors and
you sort of are looking at okay what if
it's this version of the movie what if
it's this kid what if it's this you know
what if it's this guy
and then suddenly jason clark who i'd
been a fan of forever
he was like dude i'm i mean i'm hip to
that you know i want to is he playing a
real guy
it's a composite basically what happened
is there were a couple of
corrupt law enforcement officers there
was a dea guy there was a treasury guy
um and so what i had done
is kind of combine them into that
character because i've spent a lot of
time
in the documentaries hanging out with
guys like that
and and also people who have
relationships long-term relationships
with informants
so i was able to kind of take the work
that i had done in the docs
and put it into the movie so that it's
drawn from real life it's drawn from
people i know
but it's you know kind of a hybrid
between the two um
yeah it's it's a great vehicle for
moving the story along
you know and and condensing it without
having too many different moving parts
because you got so much going on
well and it's with something like that
like a story like this
there are the people that like i was one
of the people that was fully geeked on
this story
i remember the day after ross albrecht
was arrested in the san francisco
library in the sci-fi section of the
glen park library i was off shooting
some crime doc or another
and i remember vividly opening the
newspaper
and it just had kind of like the shadowy
headlines of the story it was like dark
web
bitcoin you know dread pirate roberts
but we didn't none of this stuff was in
the zeitgeist yet we hadn't even like
really heard of bitcoin
but i remember thinking like man there's
like there's a story there it's maybe
it's a movie
maybe it's a doc but like there's
something and i was just
kind of fascinated from the get-go and
then
obsessively tracking the story as new
pieces of information would come out
and then eventually there was this
rolling stone uh reporter this guy by
the name of david kushner is this
brilliant writer and reporter has like
a nose for story and is able to get to
people
and he had gotten to ross oldbrick's
girlfriend in austin and
um and then the family and so he wrote
this
profile of ross that was this very
kind of relatable humanist portrait
and suddenly when i read that piece i
was like ah
okay now i can like connect with this
guy in some fundamental
emotional way but at the time none of
the stuff about the corrupt cops had
broken
none of that stuff was in the public
nothing had been reported on
and i think that the feds deliberately
kept that information under wraps so as
not to screw up the prosecution
of of ross right but i was knowing
people in dea and knowing people in u.s
attorney from megan u.s attorney's
office for making the 7.5 for macon
operation odessa whatever those guys
would call me and they were like man
there's a whole nother amazing half of
the story which is the crooked cop side
of the story
suddenly when i saw that i thought okay
now that's a movie because i can imagine
these two sort of people
you know i always thought of it it's
almost like they're missiles on a
collision course flying right at each
other you know
and so suddenly when i had that in my
head i was like i can make a movie out
of that
the the stuff with the corrupt cops wife
and daughter
was that fictionalized as well yeah so
it's a so
it's it's interesting you know at a
certain point some i remember like on
set
and kind of going up to it people were
like okay so what's what's factual and
what's you know fictional
what's factual what's fictional and i
at a certain point i was like i need to
pour myself into this because there
wasn't
you know when you're making a doc you're
going out and you're harvesting people
and you're harvesting information and
you're harvesting
photos videos news footage this was like
there was a limited amount of
information and so then when the
information ran out
it was like okay what am i going to pour
in here i can research it the way i
would do a doc
but really if i'm going to make this
something that's
true and authentic to me i kind of
poured myself into it so
so that's what i ended up doing you know
so when you say
poured yourself into it did you create
this story with the daughter that needed
the money for school
and yeah um i mean what it is is it's a
combination
so there was a limited amount of
information this guy
one of these cops had family members had
um you know a background where he was
jacked up in puerto rico and sort of
thrown off track so i took the pieces
that were in the public record
that were in rolling stone articles or
in the wired article or whatever
and then i was like okay i'm going to
put my own
biography into this i'm going to put you
know maybe my relationship with my
daughter
or my relationship with my wife and so
kind of build out from what's there with
uh with a personal story to it
is that a difficult thing to do like
do you do you tiptoe through that
because here you are
you have this story right the story for
folks who don't know we should probably
let them know what the story is if they
don't know
the story of silk road is a spectacular
story
because he created this
marketplace through the dark web
with you know using tor and encryption
where and and tor is a browser um
it's an encrypted browser yeah it's
basically like it's it's like the harry
potter invisibility cloak you know you
go into tour
and it conceals usage and location
and he developed this silk road platform
where
you could buy all kinds of drugs and
then
ultimately it you could buy guns as well
and a lot of other
illegal things and his
the way you portrayed him is really
fascinating too and i wonder how much of
it is accurate because you portrayed him
as this sort of really intelligent
idealistic young man who ultimately
believed that people should have the
freedom
to buy sell use choose whatever they
like
and that the people who support silk
road that's how they felt
and people that are proponents
of a lot of these uh particularly
psychedelics which i'm one of them
they like that like like yeah who who is
a grown adult
to tell another grown adult what they
can can't use would it be great
if there was some online marketplace
that was free from the tentacles the
american government
and you could buy whatever you wanted
well there was and he created it
and it's uh it's very in
in in the sense that it's it's an
important american story it's an
important internet story it's an
important worldwide story
but then you're also adding fiction
well it's it's um yes and his story what
fascinated me about his story was
you have this guy that starts out as a
very
kind of naive innocent guy he's somebody
who wants to
make his mark in the world wants to
change the world and
goes into it with an open heart and good
intentions
and there was a lot of information about
him
when i first sat down to write the
script there was
he was locked up in mcc new york
actually exactly where michael dowd from
the 75 had been locked up
years earlier right and so i sat down
and i
wrote um i wrote him a letter and
he was in in awaiting sentencing i think
at the time but i knew his lawyers were
never going to give me
access to him right for rightly so for
potentially screw up his defense but i
felt like you know i owe it to this
guy in some fundamental sense if i'm
gonna tell his story
to try to connect with him and i'm a doc
guy that's my process
you know and so i wrote him a letter and
i never heard back
and but then he had left this
kind of amazing archive of breadcrumbs
in his past you know he had
written all of these public posts on the
silk road website
as dread pirate roberts where he's
putting out his philosophy his
ethos his you know convictions and then
at the same time he had been secretly
keeping a journal
long before he had launched silk road
all the way through it up until the
bitter end
and so when he got busted they
confiscated his laptop
and when they opened up his laptop they
had all of his private journal entries
so there was the combination of his
public postings as dread pirate roberts
and the diary entries as ross albrecht
and so while i didn't have access to the
guy i had access to his words
and who um you know his
i guess accidental self-portrait in some
way or another
and so when we got into and you're out
to your question of of
how much of this is um you know
journalistically accurate so every piece
of voice over
in the movie that's that's spoken by
nick robinson who plays ross albrecht
all of that is either taken from the
diary entries or taken from the public
postings as dread pirate roberts and
then all of the chat logs all of the
back and forth the encrypted
communications between
you know knob and dread pirate roberts
all of that stuff is taken from the
documentary record
because i felt like you have to be true
to who this guy is
in some sense spiritually you know yeah
did you communicate with him at all
no so what happened was i so i couldn't
i couldn't get to you i wrote him a
letter never heard back but what ended
up happening was
his ex-girlfriend who's an austin who's
here in austin
julia v who's portrayed in the movie by
the uh the actor actress alexandra ship
she became a consultant for it um when i
was writing the script
and then when making the movie because i
felt like i needed somebody who
knew this guy who loved him who had an
intimate viewpoint on who he was and so
she became my kind of source and way in
in an emotional sense right how old was
she when all it was going down
twenties you know in her twenties i mean
and that's and that's what year is this
that's basically 2011 to 2013.
and so you know she's she in college
she's just like just just out right so
they're like
young people knocking around austin and
and for her i think it was you know what
she had told me was
initially it was like he and i against
the world you know inside the bubble
and then little by little the silk road
website became his
masterpiece and it was like everybody
goes outside of the bubble except me and
silk road
and so eventually she felt like she was
in almost like a three-way relationship
where it's like her him and the website
and eventually the website kind of eats
him
you know yeah well you did a great job
of portraying the obsession that he had
with all the inner workings of the
website and
and seeing it ramp up through the
website's growth and development when
was it gawker that made the article
about it and then it just
exploded i remember that article i
remember it very clearly like when you
showed the image of that article i
remember going wow i remember that
article
yeah because it like you know and i
think that that is true
of many of these people that are the
kind of
disruptor innovators you know you have
to
get your message into the you have to
get
get into the zeitgeist in some
fundamental way so like gawker was the
way that like broadcast this to the
world
hey man silk road's out there like the
mailman is your dope dealer and he's not
even hip to it
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience